we're back with president trump also
joining us now the governor of the great
state of texas god bless texas
greg abbott is with us governor great to
see you thank you
you now
you've been very generous with your time
coming on the show often
and you have pointed out that all
you couldn't even send in your your
child protective services
to check on do their job and check on
kids
you know about ranchers finding dead
bodies on their ranches
we know about the perilous journey but
the government
won't even allow you to enforce the laws
that they refuse to enforce
now you're left with what building your
own fence he's not president
we in texas have been left to our own
devices to
fend for ourselves it's like we're some
outpost somewhere
along some territory that the federal
government doesn't care about anymore
it's not like it was with president
trump he cared about texas he stepped up
to texas
what i'm having a hard time and i'm and
i'm sure everybody here is having a hard
time with
we are supposed to be a nation of laws
uh if president trump
if he jaywalked they'd want to impeach
him right let's be honest
but but here joe biden and kamala harris
are picking and choosing not to enforce
the laws of the land
and you don't have the authority as a
governor to
enforce it for them so now you're what
now you'll do the next best thing so the
the first error that the bite
administration is making
is they have abandoned the rule of law
they are not enforcing
the immigration laws that have been
passed by congress and hence we have
this
complete open border policy the states
can make the same apprehensions that the
border patrol can make
but we would just turn them over to the
federal officials who believe in catch
and release so
what texas is doing because i declared a
disaster
the penalties have increased for anybody
trespassing anybody who vandalizes
anything
and they can they're going to go to jail
we are working with sheriffs
man these men and women in the white
house behind me
[Applause]
very people are here so shawn real quick
yeah so what
what we're what i've been working for
the last several weeks with these
sheriffs on
we're going to start arresting people
putting people behind bars
putting them in jail not giving them the
red carpet treatment that the body
administration has been giving them
they uh they love the governor he and i
had a great
relationship along with a lot of other
people in this room
from texas and from other states in all
fairness but
very special what texas has been doing
and we
we had just it was over we stopped a lot
of the drugs that were coming in which
is very tough to do
and they have some real criminals
bringing this stuff in they have the
toughest people these cartels
these are tough smart people they're
like they went to the wharton school of
finance and graduated number one in
their class but they never did that
but they would have graduated number one
they're very very tough
and smart and what they've been doing
with
human trafficking and drugs and all of
the other things
is a disgrace we had it largely stopped
and in two months three months they
ended stay in mexico was so great stay
in mexico they couldn't stay in this guy
and they ended it uh you take a look at
the governor was saying catch and
release i
ended that that's where you catch a
criminal and you release them in our
country
and then they're supposed to come back
for a trial three years later
louie gohmert i would say they don't
come back too often to trials right
you would never see them is that correct
louis louie's a great congressman too
and uh he's the only one that might be
even tougher than us on the board
right but i will say this look we had
the relationship
everything was good you need the federal
government they need help from the
federal government
i gave it to him times 10 and we did it
and then he comes in and he stops
building the wall all you needed was
two more months and we would have had it
completed
but even so we built almost 500 miles of
wall
and it really had such a huge impact
and the people had an impact and those
sheriffs are
and law enforcement generally in texas
has done an unbelievable job
but they're getting no support from the
federal government all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else